antigua tiene 365 playas una por cada
día del año
cuidado con los pájaros
adamantón es instructor de kitesurf en
la playa de jable en el norte de la isla
lleva 20 años trabajando aquí
prácticamente crecí en esta playa he
visto muchos cambios he visto la erosión
de las tormentas hay mucha arena que se
extrae de aquí se calcula que en todo el
mundo Cada año se extraen 50 mil
millones de toneladas de arena para
abastecer a la industria de la
construcción la arena es el segundo
recurso más explotado después del agua
en la antigua la arena es extraída como
si fuera un recurso inagotable para
realizar pequeños trabajos de
construcción la población hace uso de la
arena directamente de las playas todos
los días la gente viene toma uno o dos
cubos y poco a poco destruye todos estos
caminos mucha gente aquí piensa que está
bien tomar arena de la playa las playas
son esenciales para proteger la costa de
la erosión de la subida del mar y de los
ciclones que son cada vez más violentos
desde los años 70 la extracción de arena
está prohibida una patrulla
gubernamental vigila regularmente las
playas Esta es una zona pequeña Así que
vienen con sus palas y un cubo y por
allá hay una zona mucho más grande pero
en antigua esta Patrulla de apenas 30
personas solo puede vigilar una decena
de lugares
nos aseguramos todos los días entre las
8 de las 4:30 de la tarde de reducir
este problema de extracción de arena
pero
Y esto es una gran parte del problema la
mayor parte de la extracción de arena
ocurre después de que nos vamos por la
noche
de la tarde
activistas como Eli fuller denuncian la
impunidad que reina en antigua
esa casa
8,5 millones de dólares
el jardinero sacó Arena del otro extremo
de la playa y la esparció Por los
caminos de la casa
Eso fue hace cinco días y eso pasa mucho
aquí
les voy a mostrar las playas de antigua
han hecho la fortuna de La Isla casi el
30% de su pib depende del turismo
jerrysley es un exfutbolista
internacional desde que se retiró del
deporte está comprometido con el
activismo medioambiental las playas
pagan los platos rotos en antigua es
triste y lamentable pero sin las playas
antigua dejaría de ser antigua
está a 50 kilómetros de barbuda la
segunda Isla más grande del archipiélago
barbuda está en el centro del tráfico de
arena de la región aquí Minas reales
operan a escala Industrial desde los
años 70 barbuda ha sido el depósito de
arena del Caribe en 50 años se han
extraído varios miles de millones de
toneladas
John Washington plantación sangrado
barbuda
esto es parte de lo que queda después de
la extracción de la
arenance allá se puede ver una de las
máquinas que utilizan para extraer la
arena
se observan las raíces de esos cocoteros
se puede ver hasta dónde llegaba la
arena John mushington es biólogo de
formación este activista advierte
regularmente sobre los estragos de la
extracción la persona que se sienta en
la excavadora solo ve los arbustos que
se arrancan pero una persona como yo ve
la destrucción de un ecosistema la
desaparición de la biodiversidad
barbuda está aislada y solo tiene 1600
habitantes para limitar los daños al
medio ambiente el gobierno local decidió
cerrar los lugares de extracción en 2006
pero para la isla la arena es una fuente
de ingresos esencial las minas nunca han
cerrado los que más dinero ganan con la
extracción de arena son los que
controlan el transporte
los que controlan el mercado donde se
vende la arena y a qué precio
cada día un vaivén incesante de camiones
transporta la arena a este lugar de
trituración aquí es refinada antes de
ser exportada se estima que este mercado
asciende a 30 millones de euros al año
probablemente ganamos menos del 1%, Pero
al final somos nosotros los que acabamos
con la mayor parte del daño
medioambiental y tenemos que gastar
dinero para reparar ese daño y no solo
es dinero sino que repercute en la
calidad del medio ambiente en la salud y
en el bienestar de la población los
ingresos procedentes de la arena solo
benefician a una pequeña minoría de la
población sin embargo esta industria
tiene el potencial de cambiar y
remediablemente el paisaje si vuelven
dentro de 20 años alguna de estas playas
habrán desaparecido
todavía no tengo hijos pero me gustaría
que ellos pudieran experimentar lo que
yo estoy experimentando entienda lo que
me refiero es totalmente deprimente solo
pensar en que es posible que nada de
esto
el pasado mes de mayo el gobierno de
antigua y barbuda autorizó la extracción
de varios miles de millones de toneladas
de arena de altamar esta arena será
exportada para construir playas
artificiales en todo el mundo a riesgo
de ver desaparecer las playas de antigua